[Music]
welcome to day two of next we're really
excited to have everyone here how's
everyone's afternoon going so far how
was the lunch free food come on okay so
I want to set the stage here pun
intended
there's two really kick-ass developers
that come up with this novel app idea
just like we all do so they go back to
their place and they start working on it
and they pull a little and all-nighter
coming up with this app and then they
deploy it they get a few users who start
testing their app and they love it so
much one of them goes on and submits it
to hacker news
turns out hacker news loves their app
too quite an irony they reached the
number one spot on hacker news overnight
they get thousands and thousands of
visitors but their servers were not
meant to handle that kind of load they
didn't do demand projection and so they
could not know that that would happen
and so it takes them hours the next
morning to provision more capacity to
handle this additional load but by then
it's a little bit too late and they've
lost a lot of users in an alternative
universe you have a team of developers
who come up with the same app idea but
this time they spend a little bit more
time architecting their app based on the
best practices like micro services and
then they deploy it to App Engine this
time also they didn't have to project
any demands know how much traffic to
expect the only thing that it was deploy
to App Engine they go get a few users to
beta test their app the users loved
loved it so much they submitted to
hacker news again and again it gets
thousands of visitors but this time
based on the load that the app is
getting App Engine is able to scale up
their servers to handle that additional
capacity they're able to capital
capitalize on this success go raise more
money and hire more people so let me
just take a quick poll in the room who
would rather be in the
most group raise your hand who would
rather be in the second group a few
people so I've done this poll before in
my dry runs and unanimously everyone
wants to be in the second group and my
goal with this talk second group my goal
with this talk is to really motivate you
into giving App Engine a shot and
learning a little bit about what the
second group did hi my name is Karen I'm
a software engineer working on App
Engine for about nine months now and
today I'd really like to talk to you
about how you can write scalable apps
high-performance app that ran on App
Engine and how some thoughtful decisions
while you're making your app can make a
huge difference in your performance and
scalability we'll be doing a lot of cool
demos and towards the end we'll be
taking down the data center it's going
to be a lot of fun so let's start with
the basics here what is App Engine and
how many people know about App Engine
how many of you who have used it a lot
of people Wow
so I'll just keep this short App Engine
is a fully managed platform to deploy
and run your web applications or API
services with a caveat that you don't
have to worry about lower level
infrastructure it's what we call servers
less infrastructure where you just
deploy your code and don't worry about
servers or infrastructure the goal of
the platform is to abstract away all the
complexity that comes with managing this
infrastructure and we just want you to
do what you do best which is write code
and we enable that by setting up a lot
of services behind the scenes while you
deploy your code we want our users to
have the same tools and services that
we've been using at Google here for many
many years we want you to focus on your
business and growing your business and
not have to deal with servers and
reinventing the wheel some of the
services that we offer are things like
logging hey what's going on in my app
monitoring what happened at this peak I
want to know what happened at this spike
auto-scaling
for where for cases when you don't know
what to expect how much load to expect
and we can automatically add and remove
capacity health checking to make sure
the servers that are serving your
traffic are healthy and up and load
balancing to make sure all your servers
again are healthy and get don't get too
much traffic all these services let you
execute really fast and all you need to
do is either enable one option or write
one line of code and you'll see these
and demos again as developers we just
want to execute fast without having to
worry about scalability or complexity or
reinventing the wheel together they all
work to make sure you can go from code
to Google scale in moments in short you
bring the code and we handle the rest
and if you've gone to any other App
Engine session you might have seen the
slide before it was in the keynote
earlier today and this is the philosophy
that the server less infrastructure at
Google lives by you bring the code and
we handle the rest and all of this works
to set app engine apart because you can
use the platform whether you have your
first ten users your first ten friends
and family members or the next ten
million users so let's kick tires with a
very simple demo hello world demo I have
a for those familiar with nodejs this is
a simple get handler in expressjs
framework all it does is handle the
route path compute a bunch of hashes and
then update firebase and you'll see why
that happens finally it returns hello
world with the last hash it computed
so this is a normal everyday app site
that I can run on my local system with
node run our NPM start or node run or I
can run it on Google's infrastructure
and the only thing that that's different
is a two-line config this two line
config app engine uses this file called
app dot y amal which sets the
configuration for what your app's
resource requirements are what the
network settings are things like what
service to deploy to what network
settings to use so here is my app Hammel
that I'm using the first line tells App
Engine that is it's a flexible
environment app the second line tells
App Engine that it's a standard node.js
runtime app to deploy this all we have
to do is g-cloud app deploy and within
moments your app is set for the world to
use so let's go to a simple demo here
thank you
so I'm in my cloud console here with my
app is where my app is deployed and you
can see there was there's one version
deployed I'm gonna do something real
quick I am in my GCE instance and I'm
starting a locust web server and I'll
explain what locust is in just a second
so what I did here is locust as a load
testing tool much like apache benchmark
but comes with a web GUI and i am
sending a peak of 200 users at a rate of
about 20 per second so they're growing
at a rate of 20 per second so just to
show you what my app is again I don't
have anything up my sleeves wrong tab
it's a simple hello world at the hash of
the last time stamp so as you can see I
have one version deployed but two
instances running
it's a noches app running in the
flexible environment if I go to my
instances tab you can see I have two
instances running
right now now I could just claim here
that autoscaler is running and as my
load is increasing we'll add more
instances and you'll be all good but
that makes for a very boring talk so
what I'm gonna do is explain in 30
seconds how autoscaler is working by
default it's looking at CPU usage across
all my instances and if it reaches 50
percent it starts adding more capacity
and this is something I can configure I
can change it to 20 percent if I want to
be below 20 percent CPU all the time or
I can make it 80 percent if I want to
use my resources up to that extent so
all of those escapes you very fine
control over your particular app in your
your specific needs you can also
configure the minimum and maximum number
of instances I didn't do that so by
default I got two instances but if I
want 6 I can set 6 if on one
mm I can set 2,000 so this lets you plan
for your budget knowing the minimum and
the maximum instances that you can set
so now as my app is getting more and
more load I will switch to this simple
web app where you can see the two
instances and the other three are from
my previous testing the two instances up
there are getting requests so what's
there is these these compute icons
represent the two instances that I have
in my app that are serving traffic and
the pink bubble with the number in them
represent the number of requests each
one of them has handled so far so one of
them has handled 14,000 the other one
has handled about 8,000 and this is not
a App Engine thing this is just
something I wrote for this demo so now
as my app is getting all this load from
locust at about 166 requests per second
App Engine has already started all these
instances knowing that my requirement
for CPU has increased and there's seven
instances I believe and anytime now they
should be there we go
one of the instances is now
serving more requests so this is the one
very simple demo where you can see
instances are being added and as my load
will start to go away these instances
the unused capacity will also go away
and if it could switch back to the
slides please so the hello world app
scales just fine and it's a very simple
example where a compute a bunch of
hashes that consumes some CPU but that's
not very interesting that's not real
life real life is something that has
many moving parts it makes a bunch of
service requests it does a bunch of
database saves and reads so we're gonna
try doing that for this demo I'm gonna
use I'm gonna make a small pot of Google
photos who's used Google photos here a
lot of people so in google photos you
can of course upload your photos and
then search for them which is the
coolest feature by the way so we're
gonna we're gonna try to emulate the
labeling feature and because it's a demo
I'm gonna keep it simple and all we will
let our users to is upload an image and
then see the top labels that the Google
cloud vision API is able to find for
those images and because I don't have
millions with users I have maybe couple
hundred in this room I'm gonna try to
simulate that load using the images I
found in this data set again provided by
Google for free if we could switch to
the demo again please
thank you so just to just to explain
again what is going on I have one photo
here of this construction side and I
have a simple web page that is blank
right now if I switch to my terminal and
upload this one image what's happening
in the background is my server is
getting it calling the Google cloud
vision API and then saving the labels in
in cloud datastore which is no sequel
database by Google so now if i refresh
my page you can see these labels are in
and the CSS is a little bit these labels
were extracted from that so now we want
to do this for thousands of images can
we switch back to the slides please so
one implementation which is the easiest
implementation is have one application
one monolithic application that handles
the post request and the get request the
post says hey here's my image save it
get the labels and then save those
labels and the get request will then
return the whatever result we want to
return but this really isn't ideal
because packing resource intensive
requests with user requests on the same
machine can cause your application to
crash if my if a lot of my users are
uploading their images and I'm running
heavy processing on the same machine
that has to respond to user requests
this couldn't result in very high
latency for my users and if for some
reason my post endpoint is down that
means my get endpoint is also down so
this really is not the best best
implementation we can go for the
solution here is to architect our
application with micro-services
architecture and App Engine on in its
foundation has micro services and in it
each application can have multiple
services which map to each type of
request and each service that you can
see on the graph which is the second row
is fully isolated from other services
and can be invoked by HTTP requests
further each service can have multiple
versions and each version corresponds to
say your releases so if I have a v1 and
I have a v1 0.1 each of those can be a
separate version that I can send
different amounts of traffic to if I
want to so knowing that we can t come
decompose our app into these two
services the one on the left the vision
service is the post endpoint effectively
where my user submits an image we do a
lot we do some processing and save the
the result and the web front-end which
is the service on the right serves an
HTML page with all our top labels but
this also is not ideal and we're still
running into the same bottleneck that if
my users submit a lot of images at the
same time the request will start getting
queued up because my resource intensive
process is taking a lot of time and
eventually they might even time out
which means my users won't be able to
upload more images this is not the user
experience that we we want to have and
this can be solved with harder scaling
but only to a certain point because you
will be spending a lot of money having
all those servers up so to fix this
problem we again decompose our app into
these three services and I promise this
is the last one the vision API service
the one on the further on the left side
is just the plain post endpoint and all
we do there is when we get an image we
send a message to pub/sub which is our
worker cue the one in the middle the
vision back-end does the heavy
processing of that image whether that's
running image magic whether that's
running your own custom machine learning
model or in my case calling Google cloud
vision API and the one on the right is
the same front-end service we have so
pub/sub for those not aware is a message
queue to talk between independent
services and it's also not a app engine
concept it's a cloud service which is a
veil
from all layers of compute so finally
after all of this work we have this
pretty solid but extremely scalable
architecture that follows App Engine
best practices I know you're thinking
this is a pretty scary graph so I'm
gonna take some time to walk through
each individual component and explain as
I've implemented them so first we have
the vision API and all this is is here's
my image please save it in my case I
wrote it in go and it publishes a
message with that image to pops up in
the center of the slide is the vision
back-end which receives the image
through pops up from the vision API it
then calls cloud vision API which is one
of our ml machine learning api's takes
the labels out of there out of the
response and then saves it in cloud
datastore which is a fully managed no
sequel database the service is written
in node.js and if you've noticed I can
have different languages in each service
so because my user facing API has to be
really fast
I implemented it in go this could be in
node so I wrote at a node and on the
right side is my web front-end which is
the front-end that my users will use to
see a list of all the top labels they
have this will build results from
datastore and also this is written in
node.js so I can really mix and match
the languages I want that are best for
the use case that I'm writing my app for
and if we could switch to the demo real
quick
want to do a quick walkthrough of the
code here because code rules so just
just to just to show that there's no
shenanigans going on I'm just gonna do a
quick walkthrough of the code and this
is a simple go server for our vision API
what I'm doing here is initializing my
pub/sub client in three lines of code I
am subscribing to the topic
and then I'm initializing the firebase
reference this is again for visualizing
in the web app in my endpoint the the
meat of my endpoint I'm extracting the
URL that's coming from the request and
then after that I publish it to cloud
pub/sub right here and if you notice
again it's a single line of code to do
all this complicated worker queue
communication and then finally I update
right here I update firebase with this
instances name next we have the vision
back-end this is the backend that does
the worker that listens for new images
and then just the processing and similar
similar logic we initialize our firebase
client I initialize my cloud vision
client and then I initialize my
datastore client if when I run my server
there is only one endpoint that I have
that will extract the image URL and then
immediately return it 200 response to
the client for faster latency of lower
latency then we download the image and
then call the vision client detect
labels method and this will call the
compute vision API extract all the
labels and we dump everything that we're
not very very confident about so the
0.75 filters there and then finally we
store all our labels in datastore and
the mapping here is the label map to the
count of the label we've seen so far so
very simple after we save our datastore
client we again update firebase for
tracking that instance similarly in the
in the last web front-end we initialize
our firebase client our datastore client
we allow cross origin request and then
in our home page we renders static HTML
page and then we have a simple JSON
endpoint labels which will query data
store to get all our labels up to a
certain limit and sort them
so again single line of code to get to
query data store and then finally we
return the response with our keys so
let's play with this a little bit I
already have a version of this deployed
and I'll do something similar to what I
did before I am in my locust instance
here and this time I'll send up to 300
and ramp them up at 20 users per second
so what's happening here is and we'll be
able to see it better here I have one
instance running and I could set this in
my a piano I have one instance running
that is doing that is handling all my
front-end requests now I'm going to
simulate some users by sending a
thousand image URLs at a pace of about
five per second in batches of five and
this is just a simple wrapper around
curl which sends five of them at the
same time so you can see my vision API
has started getting some requests and my
back-end is starting to process them so
while this is happening I want to show
you the cloud console again and go to
the services tab this time you can see I
have the web front-end with one version
running I have the vision back-end with
one version running and have the vision
API with one version running vision API
is a go with one instance back-end is
one no chairs and the front-end
is four instances now so within the last
30 seconds autoscaler figured out that
our load has increased and already
started spinning up these instances and
this one again is in is in no chairs so
while my app is warming up if we could
switch back to the slides I want to
point a few things out here that by just
slightly glanced over first is just the
breadth and the depth of services and
API is that Google cloud platform has
offer we've been doing technology for 18
19 years now we've been working on
machine learning for a decade now and we
would like our users to have access to
all of those cool services from
databases to machine learning to
monitoring that power product like
Google photos and you can have access to
all of that and as you saw all it takes
is a single line of code and second more
specific to our app is each service is
very specific and independent and
there's one thing it does and it does it
really well we make sure our latencies
are extremely low we make sure they can
scale up and down on their own and as as
my team start growing they can control
their own independent deployment
processes for they're bringing the risk
of rollouts down third if my say my
vision back-end service is down it
doesn't hinder with my user experience
of the API or the front-end and that is
something really powerful where even if
my some of my system is down most of it
is still up finally and I mentioned this
before my services can scale
independently if suddenly my users want
to show off my app because I'm at a
conference like this one only my web
frontend can grow can scale instances up
which results in a better use of
resources and hence my money so let's
see how our app is doing and if we could
switch to the demo again perfect I go to
my instances tab here you can see we've
spun up 15 instances not sure how easy
it is to see back there we've spun up 15
instances and web front-end is already
serving my request with three of these
instances now and this is something
really powerful where we only had to
wait for a few moments to see this this
almost real time scaling happen and so
while we are here while we are still
here I want to go back to my default
servers and this is the service that I
used in my first demo for the hello
world
with hashing
and what I want to show you is the
monitoring that we provide with our
service and you can see in the summary
graph we can show you how many requests
per second you were getting so I was
getting about 180 or something like that
the second one I want to point you to is
the CPU utilization graph where you can
see a nice curve of how my CPU
utilization was happening and based on
this I can again plan for my peak hours
and finally and this is the coolest one
is the instances graph and you can see
again for the longest time we were at
two instances and then some the CPU load
increased so hottest killer scaled my
instances up to six so this really gives
you a peek at how autoscaler works and
that's how that's what we want you to
have transparency the one thing I should
mention is this scaling is happening by
based on the CPU consumption but you
could configure it to be QPS or requests
per second as well okay if you could
switch back to the slides thank you okay
so for the final demo and will be this
will really highlight how resilient our
infrastructure is I promise I take down
a data center I'm sorry I lied I can get
all the approvals
there's processes and customers that we
need to take care of so we'll do the
next best thing and this will still be
worth your time we'll pretend that a
data center is down so for some context
all app engine deployments are multi
zonal whenever you deploy you can choose
a region to deploy to and within that
region we add a layer of replicas
replication across multiple region
multiple zones so on screen here you can
see some of our regions and each region
is in the blue row and within each
region we have multiple zones so in my
case I deployed to US central which has
four of these zones so my app is
replicated across three of those and
that really happens to manage fairly
and improve latency and as some of you
know failures and data centers happen
some of you might have had outages last
week and so what I want to show here is
if there is a data center outage we can
still be in a good position if we could
switch to the demo here okay I'm nervous
for this one I'm not gonna lie so what I
wanna tell you what's happening here I
have the same hello world app that I
used in the first demo and I am going to
start my local server and we'll do 200
users ramp it up at five per second so I
have the same hello world app and I
would be happy to show you the app so
all it does is hello world it does some
hashing and I'll show you the code in a
second but this time what's happening is
in every request it looks at the
metadata of the server so each instance
in each project has metadata in each
instance has access to that metadata
when it sees that the app is currently
in a zone which we want to take down it
responds with a 500 and this happens for
health check as well and the health
check bit is important because that's
the signal that autoscaler is using to
take instances are in and out of
rotation and so what I'm gonna do and
we'll switch back to this app oh sorry
yep so you can see I have four of these
instances currently serving my request
what I'm going to do is take down US
central 1a and so what's what this
command does is it updates the project
metadata to have this failure zone field
which is currently set to US central 1a
and as soon as that is done
okay so it's updated so it looks like
none of our VMs
were in US central 1a so just for
theatrics I'll take down another zone so
now if you notice US central one had
four zones and I'm pretending that two
of them are down half of the region is
completely down at this point and at
this point if our VMs were in the
correct zone well it looks like demo
gods are not on my side oh no okay
anyways we'll keep moving so with that I
promise there was no magic here so I'll
show you some of this code and how I
implemented this this is again in no GS
I'm curious so the way I implemented it
I have three end points to find one for
the zone of the current instance okay
there we go
two of these instances are out now thank
God so if you notice the second instance
and the fourth instance have stopped
serving requests and I don't know what
happens next the failure zone one is a
custom field I defined and the failure
zone two is a second field I defined I
do the same firebase initialization and
then before I start my server I query my
metadata server and set the App zone
field and so this is just telling me I'm
in US central one BC AF and then I have
this aah health endpoint that I define
and what it does is it gets the metadata
from the first attribute field and then
checks to see if they are if my instance
is in the same zone as my app or sorry
if my instance is in the zone where I
want a failure to happen and if it does
it short circuits
and returns 500 status code if it
doesn't just the same thing for the
second one and then short circuits with
a 500 in my route path I check if we are
in a failure zone again if the failed
bit is said and if it is sent 500
otherwise do the same hashing to consume
some CPU and update the instance and
then finally return hello world so this
is really really testing our
infrastructure and if you notice and
other instances was just spun up but
these two instances are still not
serving any traffic and soon enough
they'll be gone as soon as those
instances are terminated so what
happened here is more and more of these
requests are coming in and more and more
CPU is being used and autoscaler noticed
that and and try to add more capacity
but the instances never went healthy so
it never added them to the rotation
where it can start serving the traffic
so the load balancer never sends the
traffic back to those instances and I
think that's a really cool thing for us
to see and you can see we're up to about
35,000 requests to our instance now ok
so if we can go back to our slides
ok so what did we learn today well first
of all demos are really freaking hard
practice this a lot of times but
everything's something something
unexpected happens but on a more serious
note we are all spending hours and hours
writing the best code that we can we're
going to conferences like these and
learning the best practices but it
really sucks when a machine cannot play
nicely with our code and that happens
all the time you know some machine goes
down someone else does makes a typo and
something happens so it's really
important to defer managing those
machines to people who've been doing
this for many years and this really lets
you focus on your code and writing the
best code that you can write second some
thought and architecting your code and
following some practices goes a really
long way think about all the places
where where your app
be doing too much and then break it up
this keeps your deployments and rollouts
independent and reduces risk when you do
have to roll back a release
there's also make sure your resources as
you saw are being used more efficiently
which means a better use of your money
finally I would invite you to try App
Engine give it a shot for your next
project and it might just surprise and
delight you if you're curious to learn
more about App Engine there's a couple
more sessions going out tonight and
tomorrow and with that I'd like to thank
you for attending this session and I can
take some questions
[Applause]
hi thank you for the wonderful talk we'd
love to get more thoughts on your
decision to do the vision backend behind
a pub/sub I see you mention you're
trying to throttle the amount of CPU
scaling can you tell them more about
that sure so pops up is I'm just using
pub/sub as a queuing mechanism because
if if my server doesn't act - pops up it
pops up we'll keep retrying so I could
have used 0 mq if I wanted to but pops
up is just something I can use
on clouds infrastructure on Google's
infrastructure but in what case would
that try to increase more instances
because your your weapon and oh I see I
see what you mean so if pops up keeps
sending too many requests if my users
submit a lot of requests and pops up is
sending you know enough requests to hit
my CPU threshold then autoscaler will
add more capacity right to it and so it
doesn't matter how many requests are
coming in from hotter scalers
perspective for my app it's the CPU
consumption so I could take I could
compute a hundred thousand hashes in one
of the requests and if that takes enough
CPU that's the metric that autoscaler
will use thank you
I kind of had two questions one is about
pub/sub for doing breaking up artwork
versus task queues when would you choose
one over the other because I know task
queue has some nice features that you
can pause work in the middle and restart
it or do stuff like that right and the
second question was just like for the
microservices architecture how would you
keep all of those separate services in
the same repo as folders and then have
one a PMO file that says like here are
all my services for this application or
you break it apart and because something
we've kind of started toying with and
for us we do drone deployments so we
would have to do have a huge drone yeah
we'll file to deploy each part of the
repo for each service so I'm just
curious how you would approach that okay
so for the first part of the question
the pups of the cloud asks pup server is
really more of a real-time messaging
platform for this app I could have used
either but if I wanted a very low
latency real-time communication between
say my mobile app and my back-end server
that's where I would use puffs of more
clout tasks is more of a it's more for
server-to-server communication at this
point it did emerge from App Engine
itself but you can still users use it
within any layer of compute if that adds
some clarity for the second part of the
question
it's about repos organize those micro
services and and deal with deploying the
different the services independently
okay I think that really depends on how
you would have your deployment process I
think the whole I think it adds a lot of
value to your organization if each of
the deployment process is separate
because again it reduces the risk you
don't deploy one large monolithic so I
think it would make sense to have a
separate deployment process for say your
front-end
service where one of the team takes
ownership of it for organization of the
codebase I would say you could have the
same app with multiple folders each one
corresponding to your service but I
don't UK and then you could maybe have
some rappers scripts that CD into the
directory and do a g-cloud app deploy
and then breakout when if something goes
wrong okay thanks hi we have a that's
running in the standard environment and
in Java and I was wondering what the
future of supporting like later Java
versions is in the standard environment
or if it's something where we should
start looking towards migrating to the
flexible environment I'm gonna have 5
p.m. Justin Beck would answer that
because he knows more roadmap stuff yeah
so whoa that was loud yeah we that the
standard environment isn't going
anywhere
we're continuing invest in that one of
the announcements that we actually had
for those of you that are part of the
cloud insiders group is that actually
our support for Java 8 when alpha last
week on the standard environment so
we're gonna continue supporting that
we're gonna continue growing we're gonna
get new languages later versions of
languages it's gonna keep getting better
and both standard and flex are gonna do
that at the same time the one thing that
is gonna change that you should be ready
for is how we support the libraries that
you run within these runtimes
today when you want to access something
like datastore memcache task queues
you're using a very specific kind of
library for App Engine what we've been
doing is writing these things called the
Google Cloud client libraries we have
them out on github and the idea is that
we want to be able to use the same
libraries for App Engine container
engine compute engine and be able to
access you know all of our services not
just database it's not just the App
Engine services but things like cloud ml
the vision API a lot of the demos that
quran was giving today so when you
started thinking about how you're
writing your apps and standard any
opportunities you have where you can use
those Google Cloud client libraries for
Java there's there's
good one start looking into that and
you're gonna see better support from us
in the next couple of months there as
well
I was wondering in an app engine flex
specifically how do you deal with a
sudden spike in in traffic all of a
sudden you went from you know two
requests per second to 5,000 how fast do
the instances spin up in order to not
lose requests so in my experience it's
ranging anywhere from about a minute and
a half to two minutes so it's it's if if
your traffic is extremely spiky and it
it spikes up in within a minute or a
minute and a half then you're gonna lose
some traffic but if it's for a sustained
period of time then we'll be able to add
more capacity to that okay we're working
on making sure we bring that down by a
lot though can we use cloud CDN with App
Engine load balancer I believe you can
I saw the documentation I think it just
works with the lower balancer I'm not
sure so I'm gonna defer that yeah so
that's something that we're still
working on actually we're actively
building that out but you're gonna be
able to just use the standard Google
Cloud CDN hopefully next couple of
months we don't know exactly when yet
how many maximum instances we can have
for a part project or per services you
can request I think by default you're
limited to 24 cores per region but you
can if you want more you can request
more up to you know thousands of
instances so we can we if you need you
know many many tens of thousands we can
work with you and make sure we have
enough capacity but we have customers
running tens of thousands of cores
hundreds of thousands of course thank
you yeah my question is regarding what
the comparison of the AWS lambda
and the other elastic beanstalk app
engine features between the two in case
you are able to I haven't used either of
those but I believe 8a plus lambda is
more event-based kind of like Google
cloud functions yeah I haven't used
those either to make a comment about
that lambda automatically provisions
whatever you know the compute and all
the it's not worthless right so right so
the one difference I think is you know
we're also server less but here you get
a little bit more flexibility in that
you can SSH into the you're still able
to SSH into the VM if you have any
issues that you're unable to debug hi hi
there isn't currently a cloud API for
caching equivalent to memcache so in App
Engine standard so what's the guidance
on running a caching fleet when
connecting from flex just just didn't
know that yeah so we have a cloud
memcache service that's currently in
alpha so if folks are interested pop
into our we have a slack channel for App
Engine by the way and we can contact her
on and we can get you in touch for that
signing up for that if you're interested
in getting in on the alpha the other
thing that we have is we signed a we
have a partnership deal with Redis Labs
is one of our preferred partners for
providing Redis and memcache solutions
and they run in the same zones that were
running App Engine flexible so if you're
looking for memcache either those are
good options okay well thanks for
attending and make sure you check out
later tonight and tomorrow the two other
sessions about App Engine thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you